in a rainforest there are thousands of
different species interacting with each
other a Jaguar hunting a deer trees
competing for light earthworms breaking
down old leaves this is an ecosystem
defined as a community of interacting
organisms and their physical environment
I want to understand the living world
which is made up of ecosystems but how
could we study the complexity of a
living ecosystem like a rain forest in a
rigorous way identify consistent
patterns of species interactions we
would need to compare and contrast
multiple separate rainforests and we
would need to compare rain forests where
similar types of species interactions
had evolved independently to see how
natural selection influences these
relationships of course even just
serving all the organisms in one
rainforest is an unimaginable feet
instead we need to find something that
is small manageable and self-contained
yet that still represents an entire
ecosystem studying pitcher plants can
help with this problem this is actually
a leaf that has been modified through
evolution to form a cup that holds water
and inside is a tiny ecosystem I use
these pictures as tools to look for
universal ecosystem patterns the pitcher
produces nectar which attracts insects
and they fall in and drown in the pool
inside their digestive enzymes break
them down and extract nutrients that are
essential for the plant's growth now
these plants eat insects but they also
how
specially adapted insects and a whole
community of protozoa bacteria and fungi
there are predators prey and decomposers
in this system just as there are Jaguar
deer or earthworms in a rainforest one
of the qualities of pitcher plants that
makes them ideal for looking for
patterns is that they have evolved
separately in different parts of the
world three unrelated plant lineages
have independently evolved these cup
shaped leaves that trap and digest
insects this is called convergent
evolution I studied two of the three
types of pitcher plants one in Southeast
Asia and the other in North America I
have collected hundreds of these tiny
ecosystems from pitchers in different
parts of the world new DNA sequencing
technologies allow me to identify all
the different organisms within each
pitcher I use Harvard super computer to
process millions of sequences to analyze
my data and to quantify patterns months
of analysis have led to result I've
found a strong pattern that seems to be
driven by predator-prey interactions
protozoa feed on bacteria and in
pitchers with more different types of
bacterial pray we see more different
types of protozoan predators future
studies will determine if this is a
consistent pattern of multiple different
ecosystems but what other patterns can I
find using a different approach here
each column represents the ecosystem
inside a picture and each color
represents a different type of bacteria
this approach compares bacterial
communities I have found that the
bacterial communities living in pictures
from Southeast Asia are more similar to
the bacterial communities in pictures
from North America
then they are to the bacterial
communities in the soil directly
surrounding them I call this convergent
interactions which are interactions that
are similar but have arisen
independently unrelated pitchers on
opposite sides of the earth have somehow
selected for surprisingly similar
bacterial communities how might they be
doing this one way is through acidity I
have found that the acidity of the
pitcher fluid influences which bacteria
colonize the pictures this app this can
be applied to other areas because the
asst the plants can to some extent
control properties such as acidity they
can curate the communities inside of
them the pitcher plant can be thought of
as the plants version of a human gut
which itself is a tiny ecosystem of
interacting organisms the microbes
living in the pitcher help it to digest
its food just as our gut microbes help
us but I can grow these pitchers in the
lab and I can alter their properties and
I can see how altering these properties
such as acidity changes what can grow
inside of them in this way pitchers are
model systems and studying them can also
inform how other hosts such as humans
control our internal gut ecosystems
there are patterns to the organization
of life when you think of a rainforest
or the multitudes of bacteria teeming in
your gut remember the pitcher plant as a
tool for revealing patterns and
connecting ecosystems both outside and
inside of ourselves thank you